le pays manque d'eau de médicaments
d'essence
alors que les gains criminels ont pris
le contrôle des sources de
ravitaillement et d'une grande partie de
porc au prince Haïti et secoué par une
énième crise de violence qui a poussé le
gouvernement d'Ariel Henry a demandé
l'intervention armée de la communauté
internationale dont les États-Unis et le
Canada
c'est de la violence que la communauté
internationale nous fait pourtant si
loin d'être la vie de Jean ernest-pierre
la voix de la radio haïtienne à Montréal
qui sera les plus tôt à celle des
Haïtiens sorties dans les rues depuis
cette demande d'ingérence étrangère le
peuple dit non on ne veut pas de cette
intervention là et plus ça change plus
c'est pareil pire que c'est
la situation a d'ailleurs empiré un peu
plus d'un an après l'assassinat de
jovenel Moïse Arielle Henry est à la
tête du pays sans légit explique cette
expert
il n'a fait aucun effort pour résoudre
le problème des gants ce n'est qu'au
moment où la population
se mobilise contre son gouvernement et
existe en départ qu'il s'appresse de
demander à la communauté internationale
de dépêcher dans l'immédiat une force
internationale armée dialogue une façon
donc de s'accrocher au pouvoir alors que
le pays connaît aussi une resurgence du
choléra
la situation est très très alarmante les
médias confirme
la mort déjà au cours des derniers jours
de plusieurs dizaines de personnes
actuellement il y a 4,5 millions de
personnes qui sont en insécurité
alimentaire il y a des kidnappés il y a
des vols il y a des viols et les écoles
sont fermées il y a un arrêt de la vie
quotidienne des gens je pense que c'est
pas à nous de proposer des solutions
devant l'urgence les États-Unis sont
prêts à renforcer l'aide humanitaire
sans toutefois confirmer l'envoi de trop
penser à haïtien pour le moment le
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU doit se
réunir la semaine prochaine ici
jacaudrai Charbonneau Radio-Canada
Montréal